好，同学们好，咱们上课。
今天这节课咱们讲。
第一性原理。
没错啊，讲第一性原理，同学们没走错，嗯，还是编剧课还是编剧课啊，没走错，讲第一性原理。但是呢我们从编剧的角度讲第一性原理。
这个词儿啊现在很火。
很火，那马斯克带火的毫无疑问。嗯我也比较感兴趣，所以我去看了一下马斯克怎么说的。
然后我发现。
这不就是咱们的课程一直强调的原理吗？
咱们的课程。
是教大家讲故事创作的，或者我在教学过程当中，我的每一套课都不厌其烦的告诉大家。
人类为什么需要故事？我为什么要讲故事？故事这个东西它为什么抓人？电影电影、电视剧这个东西为什么存在在这个世界上，它为什么能赚钱？为什么受人尊敬，受人喜欢？我们都是在探究这些问题。
然后试图让你知道你在写什么，你的故事创作他是在干什么？然后。
从而得到我们为什么要这么做。
所以说啊咱们一直在用。
这种方式来探讨问题。
只不过没有人家这个词儿没有这个定义。
一看马斯克怎么说，哎呀，我才知道啊。
这不就是。
他说的第性原理嘛。
所以我们先来理解一下什么是低性原理，好吧。
基因性原理。
其实本质上就是一种思考方式。
人的这个大脑啊运转嘛。
他总得有个。
逻辑嘛。
我之前讲课的时候讲过，我说咱们。
这个这个中国的教育啊。
呃，对逻辑不太重视。
逻辑学不太重视，所以导致实际上严格来说，咱们整体社会的逻辑水平不高。
这也是为什么咱们互联网会有会有很多人。
抬杠啊或者是非常固执，就是整体逻辑水平不高。
实际要理解第一性原理，或者要理解各种思维方式，是要学逻辑的啊。呃，那这节课我我先预告一下，我非常有信心能给大家讲明白。也就是说听完这节课你能搞清楚第一性原理，也能搞清楚从编剧的角度的第一性原理，以及我们怎么样写好故事，做哪种故事。
我能给你讲清楚，但是呢。
在这个弹幕里面会出现大量的抬杠啊，为啥呢？是因为这节课涉及到逻辑，而逻辑是我们的薄弱环节啊。
我们说。
回到第一性原理，第一性原理本质上是一种思维方式啊。
我们思考一个问题，我们遇到一个问题，需要我们去分析，去研究，去找解决方案的时候，我们是有思维方式的。同学们。
一般来说就这么几种嘛。
要么归纳法。
对吧我们去找规律嘛，归纳一下子。
对不对？归纳一下是怎么回事。
归纳法我们经常用吧。
这个词你不太熟，但是听过是吧？
第二种方法，那就是演绎法嘛。
演绎一下，推导出一个结论，归纳法演绎法是吧？
这都是经常用的。当然本质上演绎法是咋演绎的啊，也得以归纳为基础，否则你没有前提条件呀。
演绎是要有前提条件的对吧？
然后还有什么方法？
比如说类比法。
类比反也是我们经常。
实际上我们生活中用的更多的。我跟你说，能用归纳或者是演绎都已经算是有点小逻辑能力了。其实大部分时候我们生活中直接用类比法。
比如说。
我现在要拍一个电影。
什么电影好呢？
我不想归纳，我也不想总结，我也不想用第一性原理去分析。我一般类底。
霸王别姬好。
啊，那我我就就得出一个结论，像霸王别姬的电影应该就比较高级。
大家别觉得这个很愚蠢啊，这是我们生活中用的最多的思维方式。什么样的企业家好牛逼，怎么样才能成为好的企业家？嗯，雷今最近最火。哎呀，像雷总那样就是好最好的对吧？我们喜欢这样类比套用，这其实是最简单的一个方式。我们生活中用最多。
然后这三种方法大也都是有逻辑的。
但是。
马斯克。
和我。
更推荐第一性原理啊地一性原理。
第一性原理的定义就是深度思考。
或者是说。
回归本质啊。
你可以理解第性原理有点和这种。
类比思类比思维啊相对，就是我不去看表象，我也不去看别人怎么做的。我从本质去推导。
我以前没有不知道这个词的时候，我喜欢说一个词儿叫。
退一步思考，就再往后退一步。
越退就越接近本质嘛。所以说马斯克理解的这个第一信用原理。
你可以这么去理解这个定义啊，第一，他深度思考。
第二呢，他从本质出发。然后马斯克理解的本质是物理学。他认为这个世界是物理学构成的嘛，我们从物理的角度再重新推导一下这件事情。所以说第一性原理实际上就是深度思考，从本质再推导一下，并没有多神秘。而且我告诉你这个世界到底哪一层是本质呢？
也很难说。所以我觉得很难退到本质去思考。
所以第一性用原理你可以理解为。
从更基本的原理去推导。
霸王别姬是好电影，这显然不是一个基本的原理。
对吧或者什么是好电影，这显然不是一个基本的原理。
我们从基本的原理去推导问题，你可以理解，这就是所谓的第义性原理，其实没有严格定义啊没有严格定义，就是这种思维方式。比如我举个例子啊，昨天有一个朋友来找我。
他要做这么一。
他做个账号。
是吧因为他认为自己可以做账号啊，他可以他也想增加收入，他想做自媒体，然后。
我问他想做一个什么样的账号？
他的思维方式就是类比思维或者叫锚钉思维。
非常直接拿出了一个账号，说我想做一个他这样的账号，他找了一个毛钉账号，说你看这个账号这个人岁数跟我差不多，呃，长得也差不多，人设也差不多。呃，也是我想做的类型的内容。然后呢，他粉丝挺多，挺赚钱，我想做这种同学们。
这个思维有错吗？
其实没错。
为什么呢？因为我刚才说了，不管是以归纳法、演绎法还是毛定法呃，类比法都是逻辑。
所以。
我们日常当中经常用这些方法，那他显然它有高效的一面嘛。
很快速呀，我现在想做个账号。
那我就照着他做呗，这想法其实也没错。但是马斯克不建议这么做。马斯克建议我们从账号的本质出发有几种本质。一、你为什么要做账号？
你做账号，你总有目的吧。
你是要快速赚钱。
是吧还是想快速攒粉儿。
还是想拉斯玉。
还是想传播一些观点，你总得有你的目标吧。
第二，这个世界上为什么需要自媒体？这些用户为什么需要自媒体？
他们为什么愿意花时间在自媒体上，然后用稍微本质一点的思维方式去分析这个问题。
然后找到你的价值点，找到你的诉求点。
找到观众的需求点。
你做账号的目的是你的诉求。
你的价值是什么？你能提供什么价值？然后用户有什么需求把这三个点穿起来，或许才是你。
最应该做的内容。
因为你虽然找了一个对标，但是这个事情啊。
恐怕不可能有两个完全一模一样的人或者人设，你的对标未必完全正确，这么说能理解吧？
这就是所谓的。
低性原理。
其实没那么复杂，它只是一种思维方式。
第一性原理更适合深度思考的人使用。
如果这些例子还不够清晰的话，我们那我们还是回到我们的电影。
我们的电影。
或者我们这个。
课程咱们说了嘛，咱们从编剧角度谈地形圆律。很多同学就会比如说有一些固有观点，我以前课上一直批评的固有观点。比如说大家会觉得电影比电视剧高级，电视剧比短剧比网剧高级，网剧比短剧高级，对不对？
我们有这样的认知吧。
但是这个认知就不符合第一性原理。我们就说电影和短剧，你认为电影比短剧高级这件事情你用的是归纳法。
为啥呢？因为一说到电影，你脑子里面想到了什么肖申克的救赎呀、霸王别姬呀，对吧？想到了这些。
然后呢。
一说短剧，你脑子没想到，哎呀，这个这个霸总爱上50岁绝经的我是吧？然后战王回来，我我我在村里杀疯了是吧？这些想到这些短剧，你归纳出一个这个结论说电影比。
短距高级，你看这是归纳法。
但从本质的角度来。
电影是不是讲故事？
短剧是不是讲故事？从本质的角度，有没有人说长的一定比短的高级，这个屏幕大一定比屏幕小高级。
本质上没有。所以你看这就是。
所谓的第一性原理。但是马斯克他认为世界的本质是物理。
这是他的毛盾前提是吧？呃，他的对本质的理解。
在咱们之前的课程上，你看我为什么说我其实一直在讲低星学历的东西，同学们记不记得？我以前在课上我说过，我说这个世界上的底层逻辑啊，有几种构建方式。
用数学可以构建吧。
也就是说你对这个世界所有的理解都来自数学，可以吧？
因为一切都可量化。
我可以用数学去理解这个。
世界。
用物理当然也可以，因为这个世界上本身是物质的。
特别是马斯克这种理工男。
他用。
物理去构建这个世界没有问题啊。
我甚至还说过，同学们，我说如果是一个学经济的人，比如说我就是学经济的。
在我人生的前半段，我是用经济去衡量整个世界的。
因为。
对于我来说，我因为不搞科研，我能看到的世界全是资源交换。
那资源交流资源交换，人与人之间资源交换信息交换的时候。
实际上就是交易。
流通和交易。
在我人生的前半段，我理解世界的本质是商业，或者是我用商业构建件本质也没毛病。
但是。
我现在。
我习惯上。
用。
故事逻辑。
当世界的本质。
第一性原理我们说是退回本质去思考问题，那本质也有个出发点嘛，啥叫本质嘛？
马斯克的本质是物理。
我思考的本质。
是故事。
我跟大家解释一下为什么。
因为马斯克作为一个科科研工作者。
需要研发新的东西，对吧？所以它世计的本质从物理出发没毛病。但是对于我们绝大多数人来说，我们其实不会不会去生产制造或者是研发某种具体的东西。
我是在这个社会上打拼。
好生活。
抢资源占取更好的位置。
所以我们从故事的角度理解这个世界。
更合理。
也就是说，我们的第一性原理，这个世界的本质是个故事。
这个世界的本质啊，就所有的东西不光是电影、电视剧、短剧、文章、小说。
这是一个广告是吧？呃掌后政治经济。
不光是这些东西，我们其实所有能接触的任何东西都是个故事。
都是个故事。
这就是我们编剧从第一星原理。
去思考这个世界。
本质是个故事。
也就是说，能够成为世界本质的物理化学。
生物学是吧？进化论。
商业经济学。
包括这个。
故事传播。
都可以作为你理解这个世界的本质。
那我们就来讲一下咱们这个本质到这儿还能能完全听明白是吧？我今天会比较啰嗦一点，因为我希望你们理解这个问题。
那我们就回到我们这个本质。
我们最适用的本质。
从这个世界是个故事去理解问题。
那我们首先得认可这个世界它到底是不是个故事。
人啊。
大部分的诉求。
我们每天大部分的诉求。
都是。
故事。
比如说我们每天都想成功。
成功是个故事。
我们每天都想赚钱。
赚钱是个故事，因为钱显然不是第性原理啊，你要钱干什么？
你得告诉我你要钱干什么？
你说我要钱嗯嗯呃有了钱我快乐，对吧？你通过买什么让你快乐，你得告诉我。
就是它不是个本质问题。
比如说你说我用钱来买多巴胺，那我就得要问你，你用钱花在哪，买了几斤多巴胺。
对吧我们得衡量下，结果最后分析来分析去，你花钱买的那个多巴胺没有晒太阳获得的多巴胺多。
或者是没有和你最好的朋友坐在河边钓鱼扯咸蛋。
来得多。
那么我们就说钱等于多巴胺这个矛定或者这个类比，它就不是第一性原理。
他就未必正确。
你只是认为有钱的人比你快乐。
对吧因为他们创造了一个词叫财富自由成功人士。然后呢，你又在各种各样的故事当中看到了一些所谓的财富自由，所谓的成功人士。
然后呢，你认为那样的人很快乐，那样的人在。
河边钓鱼，同学们，我可以向你。
说一个扎心的事实，在河边钓鱼的那些人。
没有一个是财富自由的，或者大部分人都不是财富自由。
他们就是喜欢钓鱼。
你想象了，你等你有了钱以后，你成功了以后。
你可以去河边钓鱼获取那份快乐。其实你可以直接去。
所以说你看啊我们我们的人啊。
永远是被故事所左右的啊，这只是举个最简单的例子。我之前课上也讲过呃茶与臭豆腐的例子，大家记不记得是吧？不记得的话，可以去回看一下茶就是个故事。
啊，什么样的茶是好茶，怎么样采摘，怎么样呢？
如果用马斯克来复习，马斯克一定不信这一套，因为马斯克会从物理的角度来，你告诉我，你这个茶，因为是清晨6点少女采摘的，卖我几千块钱一克。你请你告诉我它的物理成分到底比另外一个好在哪里？
所以这个故事就过不了他的第一型原理。
也过不了咱们的第一型原理。因为咱们从咱们的角度，咱们知道茶本身就是个故事。
我们塑造这个故事，是因为这个产业需要这个故事来赚钱。
需要做信息差。
对吧需要引起资源流动。
这就是。
从故事这个本质去理解世界，能理解吧？
就是也就是说我们能看到的这个世界就是个故事。
这个世界上所有的东西都是个故事。
包括国家民族政治本质是个故事，但不是贬义词。
因为世界就是这么运行的嘛。
我们在。
从这个大的本质的角度，我们再回到我们这个小的领域。我们作为讲故事的人，作为编剧。
作为写故事的人，首先我们得出几个结论。第一个结论，我们的工作很重要。
这也是为什么会讲故事的人，其实不光能做好编剧，对吧？可以做的事情很多。
因为它是个世界的本质性的东西是第一。
第二，我们要跳脱故事之外，我们既要创造故事，又要跳脱故事之外，就像茶是的故事。我们。
要讲好这个故事，对吧？我们也可以喜欢喝茶，但是我们要知道它本质上是个故事。
茶只要是干干净净的。
就都差不多，这个世界上对吧？最贵的茶和最便宜的茶，你只要别脏。
你别里边有细菌，它都是差不多的。
这是本质。那从我们写剧本的角度，那我们就要去理解，我们就要去知道我们用的是故事这种方式把它创造成影视内容这种方式。
来给大家讲故事。
什么是所谓的高级？什么是所谓的有效，什么是所谓的。
什么什么好故事呢？
我们从这个。
本质上。
就可以得出。
更加贴近事实的结论。
比如说。
什么是好故事？我们再来思考这个世界就是个故事，本质上是个故事。那为什么会出现这么多故事呢？
为什么我们要给别人讲故事呢？
为什么人类的起源是因为智人学会了讲故事呢？
对吧这不是我说的这是我第一课就讲过尤尔赫拉利说的。
他今年又出了新书了啊，同学们只认至少。
写的也不错。
就是因为。
人啊。
要获取资源嘛。
讲故事是抢夺资源的一种方式。我们通过讲故事赚钱。
我们通过讲故事建立权威。我们通过讲故事团结力量。我们通过讲故事。
欺负别人，剥削别人。
或者是控制别人对吧？全是中性词，同学们全是中性词啊。
所以讲故事的本质是抢夺资源。在现代经济社会里面。
很多时候。
抢夺资源是以前来衡量的。
所以在有些。
时后一个故事能不能赚钱，其实是衡量它是不是好故事的一个标准。
对吧啊从我们的角度，钱只是资源的一种体现方式啊，真正的好故事是说服别人，或者是说获取别人长时间的信任。
这也是为什么咱们在讲课的时候，我谈到故事，一直在说你需要让别人对你的故事有所期待。然后呢，这是第一步，第二步，让他持续的期待。也就是说期待乘以时长。
长期期待你这个故事就成功了。
你如果想变现，他自然能为带为你带来收入。
对吧，所以说你看赚钱并不是。
第一性原理。
接近地一性原理了，已经对吧？但还不是最深的一层，最深的一层是我们要知道我们从事的工作是讲故事。
这个世界是个大的故事。
然后我们的电影、电视剧、短剧、长剧，它是个小的故事。我们是通过这个故事去进行资源分配，获取别人的资源。
而获取别人的资源。
通过的这个手段是。
获取他人的长时间的注意力。
这就是。
故事的本质。
也就是说。
这个世界上所有的大故事，他本来就是抢夺话语权的同学们。
话语权。
那我们的小故事。
显然也是。
话语权。
在古代没有文字的时候，每个村里。
讲故事的那个老人，是这个村最重要的精神图腾。
撒满教就是嘛。
他就是可以讲祖先的故事，所以他成为了这个村里最牛逼的人，最有话语权的人。
他说了算。
这是人类。
这个。
抢夺资源最古老的方式。
也是最最最地一性的方式。
那我们的电影电视剧啊。
也是这么做的。
通过刚才。
我讲的这些。
同学们能不能理解第一性原理，以及我们编剧的第一性原理。首先，我们从写剧本的角度。
我们知道。
第一性原理对于我们来说怎么应用？
另外呢我们也要知道这个世界的本质啊也有多种构建方式。
马斯克用物理来构建，我们也可以用。
故事传播来构建。因为我们的人类社会啊。
是故事连接在一起的，用这个角度去理解，大家就知道我为什么从去年开始啊，就一直对很多年轻的同学说。
希望我希望他们去做短剧。
当时。
不瞒同学们说，遇到过很多抵触的声音吧。
咱们有很多同学说，老师，你怎么让我们做短剧啊，短剧多low啊。
你怎么让我们做那么low的东西啊？老师，你是不是也low了？
或者是同学们会觉得老师我做这一行，我是要进入艺术的殿堂，对吧？我要做电影，电影是我的梦想。
有这些思维不奇怪啊，显然有这些思维，就是因为我们没有用低性原理去思考问题。首先，电影为什么是艺术的殿堂？短剧是为什么是不是艺术的殿堂？啥叫艺术的殿堂？啥叫艺术？啥叫殿堂？
你从物理的角度给我掰扯明白，还是说你从人类传播的角度给我掰扯明白。我当时给大家讲过短剧的逻辑啊，如果从第一性原理思考问题，从传播的角度思考问题，短剧比电影要高级。
为啥？
短句。
是故事的讲述者和故事的。
接受者，也就是说讲故事的人和听故事的人直接交易。
我们当时讲短剧为什么蓬勃发展？同学们短剧为什么突然爆发？
之前没有短内容吗？
也有吧。
互联网上有各种各样短的段子，短的视频。
短的剧情各种各样的呀。
为什么突然爆发？
是因为突然他们研究出来用小程序让用户付费了。同学们。
来，我们就看付费来。
讲故事的人。
听故事的人是吧？或这是我们，这是用户。
故事是个啥？就是讲故事的人给听故事的人讲一个故事，然后听故事的人还给讲故事的人一个。
讲故事的人想要得到的东西。
大部分时候他想要得到钱。
或者是说。
他想要得到的是资源，只不过在现代经济社会当中，资源的衡量单位往往是钱，这么说能明白吗？
然后讲故事人给听故事人讲了一个。
故事传播了一个故事，听故事人还给讲故事的人钱。
这就是故事本来的运行逻辑。
但是在咱们的体系里面。
由于讲故事这件事情是受管制的，你不能瞎讲，或者是说我们要统一管理。
那么讲故事的人会把这个故事讲给某个环节。
或者我们叫平台。
然后。
通过平台再分发给听故事的人，然后听故事的人呢，把这个资源或者是我们直接点叫钱还给平台，然后平台再还给讲故事的人。我们说。
这就是。
我们的一个现状。
那么这个显然是不合理的，为什么呢？因为他最想听的故事，我本来是要讲给他听的。
因为他要听故事。
但是我现在不能讲给他，我必须讲给他提。
他由于不是听故事的人。
所以他选择我的故事的时候。
并不以。
最高效为单位而为为依托，他以他的偏好作为依托了，他的喜好跟他的喜好完全不一样。
然后呢，他。
在转达给他的时候，即便是他愿意听，他付出了资源了。
给了他多少，他还给我多少，他给我多少，依然是他说了算。
我们现在就从第一性原理去说这个这个故事流转的过程，显然对于故事本身来说不合理。为啥呢？我讲不了他最爱听的故事，他也不可能回馈我资源，就是这个问题。
显然不符合地一性原理吧。
但是短剧由于他当时挂在小程序，可以让听故事的人直接给讲故事的人自源。
实现直接沟通。
从第一性的原理的角度来讲，它比传统影视要高级。
这就是赤裸裸的现实。
他就是比传统影视要高级。所以说。
它更符合第一性原理，咱们也在。
课上推荐年轻人。
去探索这条路啊，我今天这节课刚开始的时候我就讲过。
今天会有大量的。
排杠弹幕啊，没关系，我们今天就是想把第性原理这个一个其实不太复杂的一个逻辑啊，让大家去体会一下理解一下。
咱们。
之前讲短句啊。
我也把短剧已经做成了一本书啊，跟他们说一下啊，咱们的短剧书已经出来了啊，想要了解短剧的创作方式，短剧的流通方式，其实故事都是相通的啊。我也无数次的讲过，短剧只不过是做了这件事情。
很多同学在那总结啊呃说短剧就是一集一个反转。最开始的时候有人这么总结的，说短剧既然两分钟一集，一分钟一集，那一集得有一个反转，然后一集一个场景就在那儿总结这些事情。
是第一性原理吗？
不是吧。
只是你的一个臆想。
只是你觉得别人好像是这么做的。第一个大爆款短剧是这样做的，所以我认为短剧应该那么做。
你们现在从本质上理解，短剧到底做对了哪件事情？
短剧来100多集，2分钟1集跟普通的电影长度差不多的。
对不对啊？
干掉电影，或者是说他有时候他的传播量比电影大。
不是因为一级一个转折。
不是什么因为什么所谓的碎片化。
就是因为他直接给观众讲故事了。
电影由于。
发展这100年。
对吧？
他有他的渠道，他有他的。
一些第一性原理以外的规则，导致你认为它比较高级，导致你认为它应该长成哪个样子？
其实都不是啊都不是。
所以说。
在这本书里面，咱们是从原理的角度，从逻辑的角度先告诉你为什么会有这种文体。
然后再告诉你他的是什么逻辑，它符合故事的通用逻辑。
以及他应该怎么去写啊，怎么去构建。另外也感谢一下呃这个。
这几位好朋友给我的书写了推荐语啊，我这里特别感谢一下呃，大鹏导演。
呃，大鹏导演是第一个给我写推荐语的呃，我非常喜欢国内最喜欢的导演吧。大鹏导演。
他的长安的荔枝啊，这个夏天要上了，非常非常好。
非常非常好的电影啊，达鹏导演不管是导还是演都非常厉害。
然后还有呃刘毅老师啊，编剧刘毅老师刘毅老师是我们咱们中国编剧协会的会长。
嗯，也给咱们写了推荐语。
嗯，战狼是他写的啊。
然后还有卢导啊，卢正宇导演大侠卢小玉啊，他也是中国拍短视频，短剧的走在最前面的几个人之一啊。当然走在最前面的还有大鹏导演屌丝男士？当然还有我们是吧？我们也是最早进军互联网的，然后还有这个短剧圈子。
嗯，比较厉害的麦芽传媒啊，何云长何总、掌相风暴啊，大伟呃都对这本书进行了推荐。
有兴趣的同学可以收藏一下，更好的理解一下到底什么是故事创作，什么是地域性原理。我们怎么去思考这些问题？
我们怎么去思考这些问题？然后虽然我一直说我是用第一性原理思考问题的人。
但是真的看了马斯克对低性原理的讲解以后啊，我也反思一下我自己同学们。
同学们，我为什么会受到大家的喜欢呢？
对吧我也在思考这个问题，我是。
影视教育这条赛道最头部的同学们，咱们现在已经做到最头部了。有为很多同学从零开始听我的课的，咱们现在是故事创作影视教育这条互联网上最火的IP就是查理老师查理师编辑课，咱们排第一。
同学们为什么喜欢我呢？我们从第一限路原理角度想。
别人为什么喜欢你？
是因为你有价值。
我讲的方法论。
帮助到了你，帮助到了很多同学，然后他获得了。
他想要的东西。
那互联网给我的反馈就是让我成为了。
这条赛道的头部顶流。
這就是。
我的价值。
但是呢。
老官老的学员也知道，我在成为顶流之后消失了一段时间。
我拍戏去了。
就是我在讲课这条赛道。
成为顶流之后，由于很多人听我讲课。
然后嘞就来找我拍戏。
导致呢我就认为拍戏比讲课重要。
为啥呢？因为我虽然深知第一性原理，但我也是个俗人啊，我有时候也忘了第一性原理去思考问题。然后我就会觉得那我拍戏去显然更更带劲儿，更正经，更更扬名立外。然后我就拍戏去了，然后就耽误了给大家上课。
后来我就反思这个问题，对吧？
我讲课目前是顶流。
或者不客气的说，我可能是现在目前互联网上给大家讲故事创作最好的一个老师。
但是。
凭良心说，我现在如果去拍戏，我是最好的编剧吗？
不是可能不是。
是肯定不是。
所以从第一性的原理的角度讲。
我受大家喜欢，并不是因为。
我。
是一个最好的编剧。
也不是因为我很幽默。同学们有很多同学说，老师因为你讲课像脱口秀似的，挺幽默的。
幽默，那你去看脱口秀呀。
那你去听相声呀。
肯定也不是。所以你看啊。
我。
我成为顶流之后，我也做了很多错事。比如说我想放大我的流量，我有段时间想放大我的流量，我会觉得啊呀，我已经是这条赛道顶流了，那我可不可以成为更多人的。
呃，更多人关注对对象，那些不是不学编辑课的人可不可以也喜欢我啊？因为我好像挺有魅力的，我好像挺幽默的。
然后我就会去讲一些段子呀，或者蹭一些热点呀，一会会进行这些尝试呀。因为毕竟做自媒体嘛。
后来发现没有用啊。
你去蹭热点或者讲讲段子干嘛呢？有人在讲段子呀。
有人在讲热点呀。
那是人家的价值呀。
我的价值还是。
讲故事创作。
这是走过的第一个弯路。走过第二个弯路就是诶，通过讲这个课，很多人认识了我。
很多人觉得哇这个老师讲的好好呀，那我们去找他合作拍戏吧。
然后呢就拿着钱来找我合作项目，那我就忍不住又去了。
但实际上。
从第一性的原理角度讲，我站在这里讲课，或许比我去拍一个戏。
对社会的价值要大。
这个社会永远是交换的。
我传播去出去价值，你们回馈给我资源。
还是应该。
安心讲课。
所以说。
接下来我会多给大家讲课。
今天这节课就先给大家聊一聊第性原理。因为我觉得很重要，而且一直符合咱们的。
逻辑。
下节课呢我想给大家讲人工智能。
因为。
deept出来之后，对吧？大家都。
非常有热情去了解deep seek对我们的。
作用和帮助。
deept。
这个人工智能。
我下节课给大家讲，因为他确实很重要。
同学们，我还是再强调一遍啊。
人活在这个世界上是为了什么？同学们。
我们从本质上从地一性角度来讲。
人啊活在这个世界上。
本质上是为了抢夺资源。
不光是人。
所有的物。
所有的生物，同学们，包括这棵小树。
小草。
所有的生物，所有的细菌。
在这个世界上只有一件事情。
抢资源。
刻在我们所有生物，所有会动的不会动的东西本质里面的叫抢资源。
在我看来，有两种重要的方式。
抢资源啊。
有两种重要的方式。
第一种方式。
加强自己。
你得变得强大呀。
对吧？
加强自己。
你就变得强大。
第二种方法。
如果不加强自己。
我们怎么怎么做呢？
忽悠这个词有点难听叫。
控制吧。
就控制别人。
当然了，这两种方法在现实生活中肯定是综合运用的。
所有的生物，所有的人、植物、动物细菌。
在这个世界上唯一的唯一的。
使命。
抹不去的使命就是抢资源。
啊资源有两种方式，一种是。
加强自己，一种事去控制别人。
加强自己工业革命。
我们发明机器。
机器是我们肌肉的延伸。
加强自己了。我有一节课给大家讲人。
征服这个世界需要延伸我们的力量。
延伸我们的手。
为什么男生喜欢武器？小时候捡根棍子都开心一整天，延伸自己，喜欢望远镜。
对吧喜欢车延伸自己，因为他是家强自己。
人工智能加强的是我们最重要的器官大脑。
也就是我们的思考。
所以人工智能是我们抢夺资源一次最重要的革命。
当然了。
加强自己再重要，也与控制别人并列，为什么呢？
因为。
在我们日常生活中啊。
这种加强自己的这种技术革新级的革命啊。
需要若干年才出一次。
但是控制别人却是一直存在的，也就是讲故事。
也就是这。
故事就是为了获取别人的资源抢资源吗？
世界上所有的故事都是为了。
长资源。
说出来很难听。
但我还是那句话查是不是中国传统文化。
但是查这个故事不就是编了一个故事，抢别人的资源吗？
就是个故事呀。
2000块钱一克的茶，2块钱一克的茶没有太大的区别。
或者是说就没有区别，从物理的角度，从故事的角度，从地一性的角度没有区别。
我们的课程。
是教大家讲故事的。
人工智能。
实际上是这种。
但是在生活中是综合运用的，下节课教大家用人工智能。
讲故事。
好不好？
再说一下啊。
咱们的书现在是。
呃，首版首发刚刚上架。
所以现在是一个限时限量的这个对折啊，半价。
优惠。另外呢在咱们平台上啊，在你看到这个课程的平台上下单这本书的话，你可以联系咱们的小助手啊，你去那个下单的页面小那个橱窗里面。
呃，下单了之后，联系咱们的小助手，可以获赠咱们的免费课程啊，也可以加入咱们的书友会。现在是个新书首发啊，呃第一批买的同学可以加书友会，咱们零距离交流，探讨一些创作方面的知识，好吧。
这节课就讲到这儿，下节课讲人工智能。